Our program is about to begin.
The AACR Annual Meeting is the focal point of the cancer research
community, where attendees gather to share the latest advances in
cancer science and medicine. With the theme of Precision.
Partnership. Purpose.: Advancing Cancer Science to Save
Lives Globally, the AACR Annual Meeting highlights the work
of the best minds in cancer research from around the world.
Welcome to San Diego.
Good morning. Welcome everybody to our early morning plenary
session on artificial intelligence.
Thank you very much for coming. Please join us.
There's plenty of free space over here. My name is Jakov Catsa.
I'm an oncologist and I'm doing AI research in Germany, and I was
part of this year's AACR scientific committee, responsible for
some of the AI content. We've had tremendous artificial
intelligence content at this conference, and this is
our crown jewel. This session here is where we are presenting
some of the most exciting advancements in artificial intelligence.
So before I call the first speaker here on the stage to join me,
I'm going to present you with a very short introduction on the
topics that we are going to cover here today.
These are my disclosures, and I just have one slide
here to outline the evolution of the
artificial intelligence techniques as they are applied to cancer
research, as they have evolved over the last decades.
Many years ago, in the 2000s, we already had methods
that we now call classical machine learning methods.
These methods allow us to analyze structured data, tabular data,
features that we extracted from images.
But for complex data such as image data, we needed
more capable methods. So in the 2010s, deep
learning came along and allowed us to really extract patterns from
more complex data. And this was supercharged
by the advent of another technology, foundation models,
just a couple of years ago, whereby you have a large data set,
you can train a big model one time on this large
heterogeneous data set, and then you can repurpose it for many
downstream tasks. Another type of foundation model
is large language model, the technology that powers all of the chatbots that
everybody's using. But one of the most exciting
applications of large language models is that they can
reason about complex procedures, and this enables us
to build AI agents around them that can solve complex
procedures. So the two technologies that we
will focus on in this session from a technological point of view
is foundation models and AI agents.
And here's just a bit of terminology on these.
Foundation models are trained on large amounts of data, and their purpose is
to provide you with embeddings of the data, so compressed
representations of the data by which you can solve many
downstream tasks. Agents can be single-agent
systems or multi-agent systems that help us solve complex
multi-step procedures. And of course, you can put both of these technologies
together, and have agents that use foundation models as
tools that can really do great things, as we will see in the
upcoming talks. So thank you very much.
This was my short introduction, and now I'm very
pleased to introduce our first speaker.
Our first speaker is Dr. Jure Leskovec.
He's a computer scientist and a professor at Stanford
University. His team was a pioneer
about AI agents applied to
biomedicine, specifically in cancer research.
Jure's team published Bi Omni, which was
the first and the most widely used collection of
tools for AI agents in biology, and these
tools are where the magic happens and where agents get the
capabilities to solve problems in cancer research.
So without further ado, let me welcome Dr.
Leskovec here on the stage. Thank you very much.
Good morning. So I'm here today very excited to
talk to you about what's new in AI and in particular,
what is new in agentic AI. What I'll talk
about is how do we go from AI as chat agents like
ChatGPT that everyone here knows, but really think about
developing copilots and co-scientists
that allow us to do science better, faster, and more
reliably.
If we think about scientific discovery, it really drives the civilization
forward. Not only drug diagnosis and
clinical diagnosis and drug discovery, but also
agriculture, manufacturing, health, and so on.
And all these are extremely complex processes that
require super advanced and sophisticated human teams.
And really, if you think about it, the pace of discovery is
limited by our human bandwidth. There are
petabytes of new data that is left unanalyzed.
Scientists have many ideas, but it takes them
time to test them out. So really, we are
limited by our ability to analyze this data,
act on our hypothesis, and test them out.
So the question is: how can we close this gap?
How can we fulfill this gap that is opening between the
demand for discovery and the supply of human
experts that we are able to provide?So the
goal for this talk is for me to walk you through our research
journey on developing an AI agent that helps us to
simulate and scale the scientific discovery process.
So this is about building a co-scientist, a partner to a human
researcher that allows the human
scientists to make progress faster and
speed up the rate of discovery.
What I want to contrast this with is the advanced AI
tools that have been recently developed.
So we are not talking perhaps about a model or a tool that somebody can use,
but we are actually talking about an agent, a co-scientist, an
active partner in research that helps us plan,
act, debug our experiments, verify them,
and also iterate. That we go from observations
to hypothesis to experimental validation of
those hypotheses. And we close this loop and we can
run it faster, more reliably, and with greater
transparency.
So the goal is to speed up scientific discovery dramatically.
Create a virtual scientist that helps us
automate scientific research,
suggest and explore novel hypothesis,
perform tasks much faster,
and importantly, tackle many tasks at the same time.
So really parallelize and speed up the entire
discovery loop.
And if we look at how scientists do research and discovery today,
how we work, it's actually extremely fragmented.
We read research papers, we collect and process data, we
run experiments and log them. We order some
materials, perhaps design some molecules, write some
data analysis code, analyze the data,
draft a protocol. We talk to our colleagues, and
only then after all these kind of small
steps,
we come up with a result.
So the research tasks are manual, slow, and very
costly to run today.
So the goal is
to develop an environment in which scientists are able to do their work,
where all these small steps
have a collaborator so that they can be run
in synchrony, they can be run in a coordinated way, and this
hopping between different tools and between different systems
is eliminated.
This is very important because the impact of scaling
biomedical expertise this way would be humongous.
First important consequence of this is that we can democratize
expertise,
in a sense that there are only few places in the world where we really have the
critical mass of scientists to do the groundbreaking research.
But with
AI-based co-scientists, anyone in the earth gets now
access to the critical mass of expertise to do their
research. So wet lab scientist has access to a
programmer, a programmer has access to a wet lab scientist.
It also will lead to dramatic time savings because tasks
once took months, now they can take minutes.
And for example, drugs or therapeutics can be brought to
market earlier.
And what is also important is the enablement of novel
findings, because these systems are
semi-autonomous, they can propose and validate hypothesis at large
scale, so that human scientists, for example, can only focus
on the most impactful or the most interesting ones.
So what we built
last summer in 2025, in my research group at Stanford,
is called Bi Omni, which is a general purpose biomedical agent.
It's an open-source project, and it's the first general-purpose
biomedical agent that helps scientists in
biomedicine
speed up, automate, and amplify their research.
And what I want to do next is actually tell you about how we build this agent
and what kind of capabilities it has and
what scientists all over the world are using it
for. And if you'd like to play with it, you can go to
biomni.stanford.edu,
and register there.
As I mentioned earlier, biomedical workflows are complex, diverse,
and abundant.
Questions might be simple, but they require coordination and
collaboration between complex teams,
to work together, talk to each other, use complex
tools from knowledge bases, ontologies, to all kinds of
bioinformatics tools, a lot of reasoning on top,
wet lab experiments, and several iterations of this,
where the result of the experiment feeds back
to
refine the hypothesis, and only through this we come up
with a discovery.
One problem that is actually very important is that if you go and use
ChatGPT or Claude or whichever is your
favorite large language model, is the key limitation that
they have, which is that they cannot perform biomedical actions.
You can kind of talk to them and they will talk to you back, but they won't do any
work for you.
And what an agent is, the key capability of the agent
is that it does work.
And for the agent to do work,
it needs an environment. So an environment is
a technical term that says that this agent, this
large language model, has an ability to take actions and
see the result of those actions. And if you think of ChatGPT,
ChatGPT cannot take any actions. It can just talk to you, you talk to it, and
you are talking back and forth.But for an agent to be truly useful,
it needs ability to take actions, to take steps
by itself. So what we have built is actually we have built an
environment in which such an agent operates.
So this agent has access to all kinds of biomedical
databases, tools, bioinformatics
tools, different software packages,
literature, web, even robots in the wet
lab so that it can talk to them and get work done by
executing tasks and delegating tasks to them.
So the key is that we need an environment in which the agent will take
actions.
The question, of course, is where does the environment come from, and what
should be in that environment? So how we solve this is that we
actually built another agent who is reading
biomedical literature in real time, every day and
analyzing what kind of tools are people using, what kind of
tools have scientists developed and found useful.
And based on our real-time reading of all those research papers,
we can
truly cover the entire biomedical science,
basically every paper on bioRxiv, and make sure that the agent has
access to the tools needed in some sense to reproduce
those papers. So through this, we build an environment
automatically by reading papers and understanding what are the
tools that human scientists are using.
So this means now that the agent has access to a
diverse set of tools, software tools,
databases
and knows how to use them. So the agent has the skill to
use AlphaFold, to reason over
PDB, to know how to use ScaMPi,
how to
use AutoDock, or whatever is the tool that is important to
complete a given task. And this environment
is large and very complex. We have over 100 different specialized
software tools in there,
different biomedical databases, ontologies, and
knowledge bases,
as well as other types of tools that are needed in
everyday research. So what this now gives is the
ability of the agent not only to think and talk to you, but
actually go and take an action. And that's very
important because a lot of scientists, what we are doing a lot of
the time is downloading databases,
setting up software packages, fighting with different Python
versions and things like that. And now none of that is needed because the
agent can automatically use all these different tools by just
us telling the agent what to do.
Another important component of the agent is that
first it has the environment, but now it needs to reason.
So the way the agent operates is that the human
operator talks to it and gives it a task, uploads the data,
could be terabytes of data, and then talks to it what it wants to
do. And the agent, what it's going to do is actually first going to
enter in a planning
stage, where together with the human scientist, they are planning
out the steps to execute or complete that task.
So it's a collaborative process about what are the steps that need to be
taken
to potentially complete the task.
And this is where the collaboration between human and the agent is
happening so that the agent is not going off the rails and do something
strange, but it's actually a collaborative
effort for the human scientist and the agent
to decide on the plan about how to complete
the task. And then as the agent goes and executes on the plan,
the plan is tracked along the entire process.
And also the agent can go back to the human scientist and say, "Hey, based on
my results, I want to enter into a replanning stage." And
again, it's a collaborative effort to do that replanning step.
And the reason I'm mentioning this, because when we were designing Biomi, it
was very important for us, for the human scientist to be at the
steering wheel. We wanted to design the system in such a way
that it's truly a collaborative experience.
And the important aspect of why we want to do it this way is
because large language models are notoriously unreliable,
non-deterministic, and they hallucinate all the time. Right?
You can ask the same question multiple times, and you are going to get
different answers each time. So the way we solve this
is that
Biomi actually asks clarification questions,
brainstorms with the human scientists with follow-ups,
and then iterates and aligns on the plan for each it
executes. What is also important that as the human
and the Biomi agent collaborate, the Biomi agent
continually learns from the scientist, that it extracts
scientists' preferences, scientists' intent, and
just the ways how the human scientist likes to
run certain processes. So this means that over
time, each scientist builds their own personalized virtual
research collaborator that actually knows them, knows their preference,
knows their ways of doing work.
So this notion of scientific rigor and trust is really
important to us because in Biomi, every
agent step is fully transparent and reproducible.
The agent self-reviews the intermediate steps and
validates them. And we have a number of deterministic guardrail
systems that take
care of the safety and prevent
hallucination.What is also important that whenever the
agent is making steps and conclusions, it actually analyzes the
literature so that it can factually ground its
inferences and give references and citations to
the original sources. And that is very important when we want to
go and validate the work completed by the
agent.
So what does this mean? This means that we have basically developed
an integrated
development environment or an IDE, which is something that computer
programmers use. But now we have an IDE for
scientists. So we call it an IBE, integrated biology environment.
Which is basically this user interface in which a scientist can
operate, upload the data, talk to the agent, brainstorm to the
agent, and the agent can then take actions, visualize the data, and be
a partner in the scientific
workflow.
What is important is that Biomi omits
discovery, both at the level of hypothesis generation,
as well as hypothesis validation.
And in particular, for hypothesis validation, there is basically this inner
loop where it's all about automating day-to-day research tasks,
keeping track of them, making sure nothing gets lost, and nothing
gets forgotten.
We have released the agent into the open source.
We are making it freely available for the scientific community.
And just in the three months,
we had more than 10,000 people
sign up and use it. We have automated
60,000, 70,000 different research tasks just in the
short amount of time.
We have people using it every day for all kinds of
tasks. And the top user basically used it
every day in
this three-month period.
And we find that also in,
let's say,
in hospitals, in
pharma organizations, and so on, it's very useful because now it's a
single tool that a scientist can use, interact with
to get daily work done.
What is interesting is through our validation,
we ask ourselves, "Okay, how accurate will this approach be and what
kind of tasks can it solve?" So when we benchmark
this on a number of different tasks from, let's say, variant
prioritization, causal GWAS gene
discovery, perturbation screen design, single-cell
RNA-seq
cell analysis and annotation,
drug repurposing-type tasks, microbiome
disease taxa analysis, rare
disease diagnosis, patient gene prioritization, and
so on. Even though the agent has never been told or
engineered to do each of these tasks by themselves,
it's actually able to solve them quite successfully.
I want to show you
a few examples of what the agent was able to do, and these were
our initial case studies with our collaborators at Stanford.
So this is a very interesting case study where
we worked with Le Cong's lab at Stanford
around designing wet lab experimental protocol
design. And you can see here
the task that the agent gets. So it's about I'm having
this particular plasmid, and I would like to design a cloning protocol.
A very simple task description. Here you can see the
seven steps that the agent has planned out that it's going
to take
to execute this task.
And about 10 minutes later and after executing
this series of seven steps, here is the protocol,
the cloning protocol,
that the agent produced. It also visualized the plasmid map and all
that. And when they tried it in the lab, the protocol was
actually correct.
And after the
trainee did the experiment,
we talked to him. And he was saying, "This molecular cloning is super hard.
It takes about three years of training, and even then,
biologists need to spend hours navigating different tools just to
design one construct. But here with the agent, I
was able to do it in 10 minutes, all in one environment,
no tool hopping, and no wasted time."
Another example I want to show you is that this is also very useful
for exploratory data analysis. So here
we worked with Mike Snyder's lab, also at Stanford,
where they had very interesting data about 30 humans.
They had their continuous glucose monitoring data, plus their physical
activity, food intake, and a bunch of other measurements.
And in the end, this data was in 458 different Excel
files sitting in some folder, and it was a
nightmare to even open that folder with all those files.
So the
scientists in Snyder Lab basically used the agent to say,
"Hey, please analyze this data for me, figure out what it is, and
come up with some interesting observations and hypotheses."
And here the agent
planned this 10-step data analysis procedure
outlined
here, and then actually autonomously analyzed the data, visualized the
data, and came up with some very plausible
and good scientific hypotheses outlined in this
box. And again, when we talked to the senior post-doc
in the lab,
basically she was saying, "This task was complex.
It was huge data mapping task of different layers of
information between participant ID and device ID and
different timestamps and food types and things like that." And
she estimated it would take her about three weeks working two, three hours
per day to complete this, but the agent was able to
complete the same task in about 35
minutes.Right? So it just says how
effective these types of tools can be for everyday
life of a scientist in biomedicine.
We've also applied this agent to a number of different
use cases, for example, to automate massive
transcriptomics and cell painting data
analysis where two people would need to work for several
weeks, but here a single person with a few hours is able to complete the
same work.
We are applying this agent to CAR T-cell
therapy for cancer
to personalize it and kind of understand,
based on the immune cells of a patient, whether the therapy is
going to be successful or not. And again, the agent is able to automate large
parts of that part of analysis, integrate disparate data
connected to literature,
and do work really effectively.
And maybe the last thing I'm going to mention about the agent is
that we've also been using it to
try to solve or help with the Alzheimer's disease.
And we are collaborating with Mount Sinai to curate and
integrate 60-plus expert-curated databases, as well
as a number of different patient cohorts and EHR
data, and let the agent analyze it to help
us make progress on this important
disease. And actually, the Biomi agent, we call it
Biomi AD,
for the Alzheimer's disease, just won a one million
Nobel Prize competition for
helping with
the Alzheimer's disease.
And I showed you a few examples of how this can be done, but
there is a lot of other tasks or other analysis that the agent just
knows to be able to do because the agent was trained basically on all the
latest research that is coming
out and can basically generalize to many
different tasks and has access to the tools and knows how to use them
to complete those tasks well. So the way we think of
this is that basically this is now the new operating system for
biomedicine, where all different databases, all different tools,
all different protocols, designs, are all integrated in a
single environment where the scientists can do their work.
So it's not just about literature review, but it's also about taking
actions autonomously.
One thing I want to emphasize is that what is very
important is that these agents actually increase
reproducibility of science. If you think about it, because
scientific workflows are so fragmented, it's practically impossible
today to trace a scientific workflow. Right?
And even running scientific analysis consistently
is a huge problem. Right? So today, science is suffering from this
traceability problem where, I know a postdoc or somebody produces
the result, and then it's very hard to actually work back what exactly happened for
us to get that result. And also that consistency of scientific
analysis is not at the level where we'd like it to
be.
And the reason for this is because of these
diffused, complex steps that scientists are doing,
hopping between tools, collaborating with each other.
A lot of this just doesn't get captured, doesn't get digitized.
It's written in notebooks, it's in Excel spreadsheets, and it just gets
forgotten.
But now, for the first time, if we have this integrated
environment in which scientists can operate, if it's
actually the agents who are taking forward the actions on behalf of
the scientists, it's all digital. It's all digitized.
So it means it's traceable, and it also means it's verifiable.
Right? Every step is documented, every step can be checked, every
step can be verified, and mistakes and errors are much
easier to be discovered, and the entire process is much more
traceable and much more transparent.
What is also important is the notion of consistency, because
today's large language models, they are non-deterministic.
You ask them a question, they're going to come back with a different answer
almost, like, every time. So we were very careful when designing
Biomi to solve for consistency, to make sure
that answers are deterministic in a sense that no matter who
asks the question, the answer and the analysis
is always the same. And this is, I think, a huge step
forward from this fragmented science that we are doing today that is
non-traceable to actually having these
traceable digital workflows. I'll show you
in two slides why this is very important.
So the first reason this is important is because our experiments show that
now we are basically able to speed up science by about 10X.
Agents are able to write about 10 times more code than humans.
They are able to run about 2.5 times more experiments
or tests in the same amount of time and just bring down the
total time needed to complete the task.
What we also see is that through these interactions between the human and the
agent, we can actually use them to train even better agents.
And what I'm showing here is that we were able to take a very small
language model and train it with these interaction
patterns between human and the scientist to actually surpass
the
accuracy of the best models out there, like GPT-5 or
Claude Sonnet. So it means that as this process gets
digitized, there is so much more signal in that process that we can use to
build even better and more
reliable co-scientists that is going to even
further accelerate our
progress.So that's why this transparency and the digital trace
of the human's scientific workflow is so
important, because it generates future training data for these types of
agents.
One important aspect is also actually closing the
wet/dry lab, let's say, schism,
and we have actually connected the agent to the robotic or
robot-operated wet labs, and we see great success.
So we can actually move towards automating the entire discovery loop,
including the wet lab as well. And this is
collaboration with Adaptive and PyLab Robot.
So,
to conclude, I really want to convey here that the
future of science is agentic, and that virtual AI scientists
are going to help us speed up biomedical research and help
scientists in everyday research.
It's essentially augmenting every scientist to get
the impact of the entire specialized team.
It's making biomedical research universally accessible,
reducing cost barriers. It's making it traceable,
verifiable, and much more transparent.
And the point is that this is not about AI displacing or
replacing scientists, but it's about amplifying and
extending their potential.
With this, I'm done. Thank you very much.
Wow, yeah. The future of science is agentic.
I think we've heard a pretty compelling argument for that.
I want to introduce the next speaker, who is going to tackle the other
technology that is transforming cancer research, and that is
foundation models. It's my great pleasure to introduce Dr.
Bo Wang from University of Toronto.
His team has published the first and most widely used
foundation models for single-cell data.
They've extended this to single-cell spatial data, and I think we're
going to see how foundation models really capture the
essence of cancer biology and can then be used
as tools in agentic workflows. Dr.
Wang, please join me here on the stage.
Hello, everyone. Today I will talk about some of the research around
foundation model and the reasoning model in single-cell domains and
other biological modalities.
All right, so, what is foundation model?
We probably heard this term quite a lot, particularly post-ChatGPT
era. You've probably seen this term in many talks, in many social
media. But on academic terms, the first
paper that coined the term foundation model is actually
shown on this left side of the slide titled, "On
the Opportunities and Risks of Foundation Model."
There are
100 co-authors from Stanford University, and
in that paper, they first coined the term foundation model and
really illustrated the essence of foundation model, which is shown on the
right of the slide. The idea of foundation model is that you can
train this bulky foundation model, most of the time language models,
using massive amount of internet data such as text,
images, speech, et cetera. And once this foundation
model is trained, you can adapt this foundation model to many
downstream tasks. However, that paper has 300
pages. Too long. Don't read.
I summarize the essence of foundation model as A,
B, C, D here. So here, A, algorithms.
Most of foundation model are based on a specific deep learning
architecture called transformer, which were invented by Google
in 2018. Although there's many other architectures
that build foundation model, but most of industry-level foundation model
are still based on transformer-based deep learning architectures.
B, business. Really the idea of foundation model is that one
foundation model can enable multiple tasks or
applications by transfer learning.
And throughout this talk, you will see how we can
apply transfer learning to adapt foundation model to multiple tasks.
And C, computing. Most of foundation model requires massive
amount of computing, particularly specialized hardware such as GPUs
from NVIDIA or TPUs from Google.
Last, D, data. Data is the new oil for AI,
but it's particularly true for foundation model.
Most of foundation model require massive amount of data for pre-training and
sometimes fine-tuning as well. And throughout the talk, hopefully I can
again illustrate the importance of data to build foundation
models.
In our lab focusing on single-cell research, I started single-cell research even
when I was a PhD at Stanford. And I
was asking myself, "Can we build a foundation model for single-cell?" This
is exactly what we did three years ago.
We published the first foundation model for single-cell data set.
We call it scGBT, which were published in "Nature Methods"
in 2024. And since its publication, it quickly
become the most popular, most widely used foundation model for
single-cell RNA-seq.
And then I quickly noticed that what's next for
foundation model for single-cell data?
And build upon the scGBT and other foundation model for
single-cell, the whole field came up with a new term, which we call
virtual cell. But the idea is to build a
powerful AI system to simulate how cell respond to different
interventions. And the steps I outlined for
building virtual cell are really kind of the three steps.
The first... generational foundational models such as SCGBD
are built on descriptive datasets, such as gene expression for
different tissues, different cell types.
Particularly, our SCGBT was trained on cell by gene
census, which has
30 or even now 50 million different single cells.
And the next step to me is we need to introduce
causal biology. One of the causal biology
datasets, I believe, is perturbative datasets.
This is what I'm doing at Zara Therapeutic, with the company I'm
working right now, which I will briefly talk about the work in the
next few slides. And eventually, I hope virtual cell model
can generalize to more complicated biological system, such
as animal, organoid, or eventually patient datasets.
So in the next few slides, I will talk about a new work I published at Zara
Therapeutic called XCell, which is the first virtual cell model
at Zara Therapeutic. And really, the key innovation we built
XCell is to learn on massive causal datasets and
predict on non-scalable models. And
we really hope to bring this kind of causal learning
concept into foundation model because the first generation of
foundation models such as SCGBT rely on descriptive
data. There's no causal concept inherited in that model.
And we really want the new virtual cell model, XCell, to start to
learn how causal data or causal biology is embedded in the
model.
And eventually, as I mentioned, we want to scale from a simple model
such as cellular model, where you can generate massive amount of
data, to more complicated biological systems, where it's a
lot harder to generate a large amount of dataset, and
eventually we want to scale to human systems.
So in March this year, we
published this bioRxiv paper, XCell, and it has been widely
accepted by the community, and there's lots of very
positive comments from the field.
And I really want to talk about the foundation
of this model. But first, nothing
works without datasets, so I want to talk about the dataset we use to
train XCell. We call it Pisces, X Atlas
Pisces. And essentially, Pisces consists
of almost twenty-six million perturbed single-cell transcriptomics
across seven screens, and overall we have 16 biological
contexts. This is probably the largest high-quality
genome-wide perturbation datasets out there.
And we draw different UMAPs and trying to inspect the
quality, the diversity of the datasets.
And here I really want to emphasize the importance of
scaling here. Not only just the number of cells, but more importantly, it's the
number of contexts we have in the pre-training datasets.
And really the key improvements to work on this XCell
is more biological context and a lot more
size in terms of number of cells.
And we also find that as we increase the number of contexts,
the Pisces datasets start to show really high-quality
datasets and recover known biology.
And we also even just look at the PPI networks, we find that as we
increase the number of screens and we increase the number of contexts,
the datasets start to recover lots of known biological
PPI
interaction. This really give us hope that with such high quality,
diverse dataset, our model will eventually learn some causal
biology.
All right. So let's also look at the AI architecture.
So
different from SCGB, which is the first generation of virtual cell,
XCell use a very different training paradigm.
SCGBT, from its name, you know it uses GPT-like model,
which is essentially next token predictions.
We use
the gene token from previous gene lists to predict the gene tokens in the
next gene list. And we find that
autoregressive training works perfectly for languages, because
languages inherently have order.
For example, "I like coffee" is very different from "Coffee like I." So the
order of words naturally matter for understanding languages.
However, we find that when it comes to gene expression datasets,
the order of genes doesn't really matter that much.
So to fix this limitation in XCell, we use a very
different training paradigm. We call it diffusion language
models.
To help you better understand what's the difference between autoregressive
training versus diffusion language model training, is that you can think
of autoregressive training as typing.
You're typing from left to right.
However, for diffusion language model, it's more or less like editing.
You generate the first round of very coarse prediction of perturbed
signals, and then you iteratively refine your
predictions until a certain threshold is reached.
We also injected lots of prior knowledge into the model, such
as literatures, as simple as you can ask
ChatGPT, "Tell me everything about this gene," and we can use that
output to help inform the models. We also
injected prior knowledge such as PPI networks from STRING,
also some other morphology features from
TempAD. And essentially what we are doing
here is that we're trying to teach the model some known biology so that
we can ground the predictions based on certain
known biologies. Based on these two innovations, we
really build the first state-of-art virtual cell models.
So we compare XCell with other models such as
State, which is a virtual cell model from Arc Institute.We also compare
cell to sentence from Google. And across the board, we
find that XCell outperforms these industry-level virtual cell
models at different metrics. And then we
also show very beautiful scaling law of virtual cells
when it comes to the number of parameters.
So the first virtual cell model, scGBD, has 50 million
parameters, and the biggest XCell model, we call it XCell
Ultra, has as big as 5 billion parameters.
That is almost 100x increase of parameter size.
And we also find that as we increase the number of parameters,
if we train on very diverse
perturbed seq datasets, the training loss keeps decreasing
and the accuracy on test set keeps increasing.
So this is really one of the first comprehensive
scaling law experiment we did in virtual cells.
And then I want to kind of switch gears that to talk about another work,
we call it BioReason. And foundation model is great, but essentially it's
still a prediction machine. And what we want is a next level
of understanding what specific biology this
foundation model is teaching us, and that requires reasoning.
Reasoning essentially is basically to decompose a task
into different steps, and you can reason through different steps
to get to your answer. So the first reasoning model we
published was in NeurIPS, and called BioReason,
Enhancing Multimodal Biological Reasoning with DNA
Large Language Models.
So the idea is that we already know frontier language models can reason
through other modalities such as images, audios.
Can we teach language models to reason through other
biology data such as DNA sequences?
So this is the first paper it's experimenting about.
The architecture of BioReason is quite straightforward.
So it consists of a few parts. First, we have
biological foundation models. Here, we use Evo2,
which is a state-of-the-art foundation model for DNA sequences.
And then we need a reasoning language model.
For our BioReason, we're specifically using Quanta3 4 billion parameters
because it's open source, it's also state-of-the-art reasoning language models.
And the idea is to teach language model
about the biological sequences. Because we know
the current frontier language model, they don't understand DNA
sequences because it's never trained on DNA sequences.
So what we did in BioReason is that we freeze
the DNA sequence foundation model Evo2 here,
and we align the DNA sequence tokens to language tokens
so that we can use reinforced learning to teach what DNA sequence
looks like in the context of languages.
So that the frontier language models can understand what DNA sequence
looks like. So this is a very bold experiment, and turns out
it works quite well.
So the first experiment we did to test BioReason is on
CCAG, on pathway variant networks from CCAG.
And we curated about 1,500
question-answering pairs representing almost 170
variant networks to almost 40 unique
diseases. And we use frontier models such as GPT-4o,
which back then was the best frontier model, to help us
curate such reasoning models.
And then we test BioReason on CCAG
disease pathway prediction tasks, and we find that
as we increase the number of
parameters, we get better results.
But more importantly, when we apply reinforced learning
to teach the language models about the DNA sequence
tokens, the language models start to understand better about
pathways, about disease, and therefore does a better job in
predicting disease pathway associations.
So this is a very interesting finding that if we
teach the language model reasons through different biological data, the
language model eventually start to understand biology.
And recently, we published a second BioReason paper.
We call it BioReason Pro,
which is a reasoning model to understand protein functions.
So, this is a collaboration between University Health
Network and also Arc Institute and Vector Institute.
And the idea, as I mentioned, is can we teach language
model to understand protein
functions? We all know that AlphaFold and other models kind of
solve the problem from protein sequence to understand protein
structures. However, there is still a big gap to understand protein
functions, and this is exactly what this model is designed to do.
And we notice this huge gap because there's over 250
million proteins in UniProt, but less than
0.1% have been experimentally annotated.
So the idea is can we build an AI model to start
help biologists understand protein functions and therefore better
annotate the protein functions?
And here, when we talk about protein functions, we kind of take a very
narrow perspective. We're specifically focusing on gene
ontology or GO terms, and specifically such as biological
processes, molecular functions, cellular components, et cetera.
So it's a very narrow perspective to tackle these protein functions,
but this is the first step.
So the dataset we curated to train language model to understand
protein functions coming from UniProt, and specifically we
curated about 130,000 proteins from
different organism in UniProt, and then we generate reasoning
data using GPT-5 to help us train the language
models to understand the reasoning steps of
protein functions.However,
one of the first challenge we found to build this reasoning
model for protein functions is there's no good
tokenizers for GO terms. We all know that GO terms have
hierarchical structures. Most of the time it's multi-label.
It's extremely messy. So what is the best way to really
teach the language model what's a token of GO terms?
So in order to build this tokenizer for GO terms, we
first train a foundation model, we call it GoGPT,
and essentially, it's a supervised model that teaches the model what
the GO labels look like. And we use very
standard way to build this supervised machine learning
model, GoGPT. And we find that just
by supervised learning, the GoGPT already kind of achieve very
impressive accuracy in understanding the GO terms.
But bear in mind, this is a pure supervised learning method
that trying to build a reliable tokenization method
for incorporate the GO terms.
So once we have everything, we start to build this very
complicated reasoning language models to help us understand and
annotate protein functions. And specifically, the input
to this BioReason Pro has three sets of tokens.
First, the ESM3 tokens, basically is the sequence
information of proteins, and the second one is a GO encoder, which
we just trained from GoGPT, and then we have also
language tokens from Qwen 3.
And once we have these tokens, we merge everything together, we
apply reinforced learning on the reasoning datasets from GPT-5, and
then we teach Qwen 3 about the reasoning steps to
understand protein functions.
Again, we use very standard reinforced learning to teach the model
how to reason through different steps, and this is very standard reinforced
learning
invented from DeepSeek, which is very early reasoning
models in language side.
And we observe very stable training losses, and
we kind of give very high confidence that the model is relatively
well-trained with reinforced learning.
So once the model is trained, the first way to
validate this model is we use the approach called
LLM as Judge. It basically is just ask more
of advanced frontier model here, especially GPT
5.1, to say, "Do you like the
predictions in comparison to the ground truth?" And we find
that with proper reinforced learning training, language models
start to understand the protein sequences and predict
different stepwise reasoning datasets for understanding
protein functions. And overall, even using
language model as a judge,
GPT 5.1 think the predictions from
our BioReason Pro most of the time is better than many other
baseline methods.
And we also perform out-of-context test.
We look at the proteins that have extremely low
structure similarities to the proteins in the training dataset
in the hope to test the generalization capacities of
BioReason Pro, and we find that our BioReason Pro generalize
very well to proteins that have little or less
similarities to the proteins in the training datasets.
And overall, we find that
by teaching language model to understand the protein
sequences and therefore reasons through protein functions, BioReason
Pro does extremely well across different
domains of GO terms, and then across
different structure similarity spectrums of different
proteins. So this represents the state-of-arts method
to understand protein functions.
And this really introduce a fundamental shift
in building foundation models. The idea is
that the language models, the frontier language model is trained
so well already, they have very impressive
reasoning capacities. And the next step is really to teach
these language models to understand biological sequences.
Although they never was trained with biological sequences, but
with proper alignment, with proper reinforced learning,
this frontier language model can do actually really well job to
understand biological sequences.
We also did human evaluations, where we invited
27 protein experts or biologists, and then
to kind of evaluate which one is better
in terms of the humans' annotation versus the models' predictions
across almost 200 different novel proteins that were not
included in the training dataset.
And surprisingly, we find that
in one of the models, BioReason SFT,
almost 80% of the predictions from the BioReason model
are better than human annotators.
So this is very impressive because for one, BioReason
Pro generate reasoning predictions much faster than human
annotators. But two, 80% of the time,
we actually find that the prediction from BioReason Pro is actually
higher quality than human annotators.
And this is true across different domains, such as
molecular functions, biological processes, cellular components, and
also this is true across different
spectrum of similarities of different
proteins.We
open source the model in this link, so all the
model data sets,
and you can even also put your favorite proteins into this link.
And in fact, we released this model about less than
two weeks ago, and there's already tens of thousands of
users
try our model with their favorite proteins, and we receive
quite positive comments about the capacity of BioReason
Pro in understand the protein functions
by just input the protein sequences.
So please try our model using this link and send us
any feedbacks you may have.
All right, so what's next? I talk about virtual cell
models such as scGPT and ExCell. I talk about
bioreason models, particularly bioreasons through DNA sequences,
bioreasons through protein sequences.
And a natural next step is bioreason to
understand cells. So we are working on a virtual cell
model that can reasons through natural languages.
And really the idea to build such complicated
reasoning model is to start to mine existing literatures
and using known knowledge graphs and then using known
biological processes to train language models to help us
understand lots of cellular data sets such as gene
expressions, taxic, and et cetera.
And overall, what we really want to understand is how
cell responds to different interventions and to
reasons using languages.
I want to conclude my talk using really kind of
a quote from Jensen Huang, who is the CEO of NVIDIA, is
that we are at a era where we can start
to engineering biology or engineering
cells using the context of virtual cell.
As we transform biology into engineering, the
effect start to compound. We see exponentially improving
results using these more advanced languages or agents from
previous speakers, and we really see huge
improvements at a much faster pace to understand different
biological modalities.
All right. With that, I want to give credits to all
the students. They did most of the work. I'm just the one who talk here.
Haotian and Chloe are the main driver behind scGPT, which is
the first foundation model in single cell.
Chloe, Neil, and Mehran are the main drivers behind
ExCell. And Adeeb and Hani are collaborators, the leaders
in the two bioreason papers. And all the
paper data weights are open sourced, and
feel free to try our models and send any comments you may have.
Thank you very much.
We have seen the power of foundation models and how they can learn
structure from unstructured biological data.
Before we've seen agents, how they can help us automate procedures.
I think a key question now is: How can we take these technical
advancements and actually deliver them to our patients in
the clinic? And that is the topic
that our next
speaker will speak to, and it's my great pleasure to introduce Dr.
Suchi Saria from Johns Hopkins. She's an AI researcher
and has done a lot of seminal work in AI.
But then she went one step further, and she actually delivered
some of these results to the clinic, and she did it
through prospective, multicentric
evaluation with mortality endpoints.
And I think that's the highest bar for evidence in oncology, and
that's what we ultimately need to see as we translate these
technologies towards the clinic.
So without further ado, please, Dr. Saria, join me here on the stage.
Thank you for having me. Can you raise your hand if you're a practicing
clinician?
Okay, great. And then can you raise your hand if you frequently
use real-time clinical AI as part of your decision-making
process today?
That's
perfect.
You may not want to answer this, but I'm curious.
Can you raise your hand if you feel like
it's really not obvious if any of the tools that are available to you are good,
decent, verified, validated, and as a result, you're very fearful
of where care is headed if you're being forced to use
AI at the point of care?
Cool. Thanks for responding. So,
as Jakob described, I started my
research career focusing on model building and
developing new technical architectures for making sense
of large-scale, multimodal time series
data sets
broadly, and in particular, when we think about electronic
health record and the kind of massively multimodal data sets that
are present in electronic health record.
Challenges also that exist as a result because these are
data sets that are a byproduct of care, which
means there are biases embedded in the data.
There
could be variation site to site in which the way the data are collected or even
across clinicians. And so the kinds of methods we need are
different from what we might need in other
domains.Further, the stakes are much higher here,
and I believe we need methods that can really augment frontline
clinicians. So in other words, methods that can build trust.
And so that's been the career arc on the research front of the
work we've led. And then in end of
2018, early 2019, as we started to see more and more
evidence for how these models were becoming more and more
powerful. And in fact, a lot of the models we talk about
today, like transformer-based models, first started to show up in the research
literature in 2017. So as we started to apply these
technologies and started to see how the models and the architecture were
becoming more and more powerful, the next question was,
how are we going to actually make use of these within care?
And when I first started this work, I thought, "Well, that's easy.
I just have to
engineer a system that can deliver it.
And obviously, if the research shows that these models are really high quality,
and if I can find a way to deliver it, then
clinicians will adopt it. Boom. And we'll get some fabulous
results." But that's not how it turned out.
What I started realizing was that there were many barriers to translating these
models, including
things like how do we translate it in a way that it's easy to use,
easy to adopt, builds trust with frontline clinicians,
and also from a regulatory standpoint, how do we think
about
deploying it in a way that's safe, reliable,
and responsible? And what that means is it's not just that the model
was performant in some offline datasets.
But as we implement this model in one clinic, the second clinic,
and third clinic, as we implement these models across
pre-COVID, COVID, post-COVID, and in just everyday
care as practice changes, the models stay performant,
and we understand performance as we implement and deploy
them, and we're able to track and measure and understand impact.
And so that's really the journey that I will describe a little bit
today in terms of the work we're doing.
Disclosure, I'm founder and CEO of Bayesian Health.
Like I mentioned, the company we spun out of Hopkins with almost a decade of work.
I'm also an endowed chair at Johns Hopkins doing research in
this space, and a conflict of interest policy
oversees all of the work produced on both sides and
manages work on both sides. Okay. So
what's the problem statement?
Care is reactive by default today.
What that means is,
in a way, when a patient is entering the room, you're doing the best
you can, given the little bit of time you have to gather
information about this patient's history and to do what you need to do.
And as a result,
you see a lot of variability across maybe it's a busy day,
you had less time, maybe
there's a wide difference or gap
between clinicians with different kinds of experience.
There's also
depending on what tools happen to be implemented and how easily the
EMR is set up, you may have access to data from past settings
or not. And as a result, there's a lot of variability in the quality of care that
we give. And is there an opportunity to flip it?
Which is instead of being reactive, is it possible to have more
proactive evidence-based care? It's the kind of thing we've been talking
about in research settings for a long time, but the question is,
what does it take to deliver that? And ideally,
there are real-time clinical intelligence or clinical AI
layer that augments the care team at the frontline,
which
is tirelessly reading through the record, not just from this encounter,
but past encounters, pulling all the
relevant information, synthesizing this in
real time to call your attention to critical bits that you might have missed,
making it easy to learn from the expertise of
clinicians and high-quality clinical decisions that have come
to date so that you're bringing high-quality, consistent care to every
visit. And that's what we want to enable and what I
think is possible.
And so I'll give examples of the work we've been
doing to work towards that.
Now,
the problem with current tools, if you're a practicing clinician, you see
tools that may be implemented through the electronic health record.
Commonly, the challenge is that the
ability to synthesize massively multimodal datasets is quite
hard. And so there are really two breeds of tools that you see today.
One type is effectively old school, simple,
rules-based or analytic alerting systems.
Like for instance,
most of you who practice have probably seen some alerting system
for sepsis, which is a leading cause of hospital deaths.
And in that example, what most clinicians would describe is
that basically, these alerts,
there are a lot of alerts. It's mostly nuisance.
It's a lot of noise. They're mostly disliked because they're not
offering a lot of true, helpful guidance.
And
when you look at data
in these cases, basically very often they miss a lot of cases.
They're often flagging or alerting once a treatment has already
begun. The true alert to false positive
alert ratio is extremely low. So, 50 alerts to find a
single case, which means a lot of noise.
And then as a result, they get very little adoption.
And so
that's the hurdle we have to cross in trying to
build tools that can drive much higher adoption.
And so what are the challenges in building these tools?
So the first is that in many of these condition areas, I'll give you some
examples of areas we've been working in, like
sepsis.In many patient safety quality
areas, these are what I call needle in a haystack problem, which
means
the prevalence of these conditions is typically in the hospital population or ED
population, something close to 2%, 3%, 4%.
It is not 70%. Second,
simple rules-based alerts create a lot of alarm fatigue because there's a lot of
heterogeneity in the way these symptoms present
across patient populations. So rather than carrying one average, what you
really need is the ability to learn variations and
subtypes from this large amount of data.
Next,
when you're trying to do these learning-based methods from multimodal data, it's
very easy to overfit to large-scale multimodal
data, and in the process of learning
the targets, essentially what you use as your--
When you're building any learning method, you need a notion of ground truth.
What do you consider as a case versus a control or what do you use
as in this concrete example, say, sepsis versus not sepsis, or when
did sepsis occur? And
historically, to get this kind of data
at very large scale is very hard. So what people do is
basically use simple labels that are extracted from the electronic health
record, like billing codes, which are very noisy labels,
and as a result, you get a lot of garbage in, garbage out.
And finally, for these methods to be useful, you need to train them so
that not only are they finding a needle in a haystack,
but they're also finding them in a timely fashion, right?
So for instance,
in many of these early detection problems, what you really want is not to just
detect it and detect it after the fact, after treatment's begun.
You want to detect it early. So how do you
solve this super hard signal-to-noise problem?
And that's sort of the model-building problem that needs to be solved.
So the work that we've done over the years has been on first--
And here's sort of the four-part architecture that has allowed us to
make progress, and I'll unpack pieces of this as I go.
So the first is the ability to integrate and interact with the
EMR so you have real time, not just text data
or not just labs data, or not just vitals data, but really
real-time longitudinal data for every
patient that's walking in the door.
And that means integrating with the electronic health record so that
you have the ability to ingest and process that
data in real time, put AI models on these
data, and then be able to put results back into workflow, in clinicians'
workflow, so that they can see the outputs and act on it.
So that's sort of the first part. And building that is hard
because
there's a lot of data, and the ability to integrate and synthesize with the
electronic health record in real time
requires a lot of technical work. Now, it turns out
in the beginning when we did this kind of work, we didn't think this was as
important. We just thought we had amazing models.
So because the model outputs were so good, it would just work.
But what we found was that unless the model outputs were
very much embedded in real time within clinician
workflows, the adoption was going to be very, very difficult.
So as a result, we had to build this kind of real-time integration layer.
The next piece is the machine learning AI methods that
make sense of this data in real time.
And so here,
mixture of expert-type models that allow us to
model subtypes and variation, and I'll, in the next two slides, go a little bit
more into it. Once you have these models producing
real-time outputs, then moving it back into clinical workflow,
and one of our realization was that if you're moving it back into workflow just to
drop a flag or an alert, that isn't as
helpful to clinicians as it is to be able to have full
workflows. And so as examples, workflows
where effectively we're
catching, flagging, summarizing why the model flagged this case
in the first place so that it's transparent, it's not a black box.
Facilitating assessments from the clinical team and the care team.
Next, being able to then proffer up
treatment coordination across the care team so that if they agree this
person has this complication, they can rapidly link to
order sets or link to orders in order to get done what they need to get done,
as well as proffering up documentation so that you're able to then
document and wrap up the work that's needed to
close that
piece of episode. So essentially, the workflows that
make it possible to act on that signal in order to realize
value from start to end is just as critical.
And then finally, some level of a monitoring and governance
layer so that you're able to measure and
monitor in real time if the system is performing,
and also detect if, for instance, there are drifts and shifts that
are causing the system to deviate.
In many of these areas,
my team's written over 50 papers. So I don't cite all of the
papers in this particular presentation, but if you just go to my
Google Scholar, you should be able to find papers on these topics if you're
curious.So let's talk a little bit about
the multimodal AI I spoke about. And so
here today, when most people think of large
language models, which are basically transformer-based models
or transformer-based architectures for text data, what we needed to do
was to broaden these transformer-based models, not to just
incorporate text data, which is in the notes, but to incorporate
all the thousands of other kinds of modalities we get in the EMR,
like your labs, your vitals, your medications, your treatments.
And some of these are event-based data, some of these are continuous time series
data. They're occurring over time, and the idea was, how do
we integrate these diverse modalities into a single signal?
And in doing so, for being able to make high-quality clinical
models, we really needed the ability to understand and learn
about subpopulations. And so here, essentially, we
use these mixture of expert-type architectures that we've designed
with these kinds of data sets in mind.
And what these do is allow you
to integrate lots of different kinds of signal, learn these
experts that are pointed towards subpopulations as well as
modalities and integrate this to
produce signal. And when we do so, what we find is over
existing alternatives,
basically the ability to reach much
higher sensitivity compared to existing models.
So, above 80% range, which is how the FDA likes to think
about it as a good diagnostic. So 80%, 85%, 90%,
but doing so not by heavily compromising on positive predictive value.
So being able to do so while still reducing alert volume of existing
models where they have significantly lower sensitivity,
but 20 to one, 30 to one, and here we're taking it down to three to
one. So in other words, far higher positive predictive value
and simultaneously improving lead time means these models are able to catch the
condition against standard of care much sooner, and where every
hour matters in terms of impact on care outcomes,
this is critical.
And so here's, for example, a paper below that
details-- This is the most recent paper.
It's actually getting presented this week in Brazil as I speak,
but it's the most recent paper of a sequence
of papers we've written on this topic of architectures for
integrating diverse kinds of data to be able to build high-quality
clinical AI models.
So
we have the models, and then I said I'll talk a little bit about the workflows.
So here, for instance, what the workflows are doing is these are modular
agents embedded into the EHR to support end-to-end workflows.
And what these modular agents are doing is individualizing risk,
flagging and explaining why, reducing friction by teeing
up order sets and documentation automatically, and then
enabling reporting so we understand which
patient was flagged, what happened in response.
Did the clinician ignore it, or did they respond?
How long did it take them to respond?
Did they confirm or ignore or disagree?
If they confirmed, did they give the relevant treatment?
And what that long-term reporting does is not only allows us to
understand system behavior but also understand human machine
teaming performance. In other words, is the system performing the way we
expect to? Are the clinicians who are over-relying on the system, are the
clinicians who are under-relying on the system?
And that allows us to debug the deployment of these kinds of models.
And by doing so, we've
now implemented the
system in a variety of health systems around the country and have
been able to see consistently 80% to 95% clinical
adoption, which means every time a patient is flagged,
in 80% to 90% of these cases, clinicians go in,
they seek it out, they look at the review report, they review
the report, they agree, disagree, and they submit an analysis.
And if they agree, they do the follow-up treatment as appropriate.
And then, like I'd mentioned, the last piece of this four-part workflow was the
governance piece. And here, essentially,
starting in 2019, I started working through a center of excellence funded
by the FDA at Hopkins on research on deploying these
models safely. And
essentially the questions we wanted to ask was, as we
deploy these models, maybe we are doing an initial
evaluation pre-deployment. But as time progresses, how
do we know that the models are continuing to work? So that's one question.
Another question was that before we go and we measure performance, how
do we know, from an approval perspective, how do you know
what are the populations it's working well on versus it's not working well on?
And in real time, as we
monitor and observe that system performance is going down for any number
of reasons, how do we do root cause analysis to
identify what are the subpopulations where things may be going
wrong so that we have the ability to
mitigate risk and close the loop? And so those are the kinds of
methods that we are implementing through this oversight
piece into all the models we're deploying.
And so now I'll show you an example case
study. So this is
like I alluded to in the beginning, sepsis is the number one cause of death, excess
days and readmissions. This particular case study is
data presenting from implementing this at a single system
at first called Cleveland Clinic.
Cleveland Clinic is a 20-hospital system spread
across multiple states in the US.They
already have a very high standard of care, and the question was, could
AI or the deployment of this kind of an AI augmentation
layer dramatically improve the quality of care at their system?
They had spent quite a bit of time optimizing the existing
EMR-based alerts to improve early detection.
They found that most of these alerts were missing a lot of cases.
In most scenarios, when the patients were getting alerted,
86% of the alerts were happening after treatment had already initiated.
In other words, there wasn't much of an early detection
result that they were getting. And there was a lot of alerts,
and so there was an opportunity to improve physician experience by
improving the quality of the tooling there.
And so what we did was,
so the partnership here was around an end-to-end infrastructure to enable
early identification to treatment to documentation to
abstraction. And before
deployment, one of the things we did is we implemented it at
their site, and then we measured performance both
across all patient populations, but also across
sub-populations. This happens to be sample data,
so reviewing all of that data would take a long time in the context of this
keynote. So I just wrote down one slide with some example
data, and this is actually a multi-center--
This is evaluation that was done across four different health
systems on populations related to oncology.
Now, this is sepsis detection in oncologic patients.
Now, it turns out in this case, because many
patients look like they already have neutropenic fever, it is actually
extremely easy to miss sepsis, so detection is especially
hard in these cases. And what I'm showing you here is the ability to get very
high sensitivity and specificity in these
populations.
And so step one, we're showing that we're able to achieve very
high performance. And so this is what it's showing here is
aggregated across Cleveland Clinic, the ability to
identify many more cases, so that's almost 60% improvement
over existing tool. But more importantly, not just identification,
but early identification. So almost 400% improvement
over the existing tooling in being able to identify cases
earlier and meaningfully earlier, so three and a half hours
earlier on average. So this is median lead time.
And then simultaneously in this, what we're showing is almost 10X reduction in
alert volume. So at a 450-bed hospital, they saw
7,000 fewer alerts per month, which is amazing from a frontline
care experience. So then the next thing we did is once we go live
in the reporting, we measure what is happening in response.
And what we're able to show is consistently over a long period of time,
80% to 90% adoption, which is very exciting.
And so if you're able to do earlier detection and you're able to drive
adoption, you should see
meaningful reduction improvements in outcome.
And so here what we're showing is in a pragmatic,
simultaneous case control study, basically a very
meaningful reduction in delays to
treatment. So patients
are getting treatment earlier. And
simultaneously what we're observing is shorter length of
stays and reduced mortality.
And so this is extremely exciting and the ability
to
be able to deploy these tools to not just have
an insight, but to drive action is ultimately what impacts patient
outcomes. And now, like I described, this is now
deployed at the bedside for every single patient that visits the Cleveland
Clinic.
I spoke a little bit about this case study.
I want to talk a little bit about the adoption component.
And in 2022, we wrote these trio of
papers that came out on the cover of "Nature Medicine." Here are two of them,
where one of them focused on this pragmatic case control study
across five sites and how we achieve those outcomes.
But two of the three papers also focused on driving
adoption and studying adoption. And when we studied
adoption, there was a quantitative paper that focused on studying
quantitative adoption. But what was also really interesting
is a qualitative paper that focused on human
factors methods for understanding how clinicians build trust
and how clinicians build adoption.
And this was really
a
starting point for designing these kinds of systems, for being able to
not just make systems that are highly accurate, but to build
systems that get adopted and used.
Because if we can't do that, we're not going to drive outcomes.
And so at a super high level, I'll describe some of our learnings,
and I call this at a high level as an activate
framework. And so the first is the high-quality AI
that monitors and tunes based on your population.
So your ability to
monitor and really learn about sub-populations, understand clinical
practice, understand clinical behavior to surface clinical signals
within workflow that is deeply contextualized.
So it's not like one of those, you have those assistants or interns that don't
understand your context and they are...
like interrupting you out of context, and that doesn't build
trust. Instead, what you want, signals that really understand the patient
longitudinal context, but also the caregiver context to be able to surface
signals at the right moment so that they can get acted on.
The second is when you're implementing these models, how do you implement
a collaborative change management model?
And what that means is you want to think about what is the existing care process
and how you're augmenting it, and then how are you building a common
understanding of what are the goals we're trying to
achieve, what are the mechanisms by which we're trying to achieve the goals, and
align on workflows to drive change and then measure and
hold people accountable in driving them.
So this isn't just a technology problem, there's also a people problem, right?
You need to change the organization's culture to be able to
adapt and integrate these models within their care, and
how you do that in its own right deserves a lot of
thought process and thinking, and that's basically what encompasses this.
The third is tech-enabled process improvement, because today,
people are already within health systems used to doing things to improve patient
outcomes, right? We have quality improvement or performance improvement they're
called. And the way people do that is very often through checklists
and education protocols. But those are very expensive and hard to
maintain, and they often don't survive the test of time.
In other words, you're very focused on one initiative today, and something else
comes along, and people get distracted, and they forget.
So what we're doing here through infrastructure is to hardwire
high-quality ideas within workflow.
And what that means is high-quality signals combined with high-quality
workflows and embedding it in a way so that they're easy to use and adopt.
And finally, incentivized engagement, which is: Is there a
way to build workflows that make the right thing the easy thing to do?
In other words, if you're taking away some nuisance, terrible workflow,
and you're implementing workflows that save the frontline clinicians
time, that make their job easier, they're more likely to adopt it.
So you want to think about how do you also remove barriers and
ease pain, and drive value in implementing these kinds of
systems.
And so I'll close with the second case studies.
This is an example of work we did with Mayo Clinic,
with our collaborator, Dr. Jacob Strand, who's the chair of palliative care
there. And this is a new use case. This is not in sepsis,
just to show you a completely different area.
In this example, what I'm showing you is a case you'll recognize.
In this particular case, not a patient with cancer, but instead advanced heart
failure, though this is a story you'll frequently see in oncology.
Basically, it's a case where a patient,
68-year-old woman, she kept coming in, multiple
hospitalizations. And each course,
she was only deteriorating further and further, but
in none of these hospitalizations,
her need for palliative care was flagged, and no one had those goals of
care conversation. Fast-forward, as we implemented the system
in palliative care,
for tackling unmet palliative care at Mayo Clinic, what we
saw was effectively
these patients are now getting reliably identified earlier.
By getting identified earlier,
clinicians on the palliative care team now have visibility across the entire
system to know who are the patients who need it.
Then based upon the amount of resources available, they can triage and rank
patients very quickly and make sure the patients who need it are
now getting it, and then there is a way, again, the workflows make it really
easy to be able to do the follow-through that's needed, and we're starting to see
the impact on outcomes. So first of all,
we're seeing more patients are getting palliative care
consults. When a patient's getting flagged, they
had a previous alerting system, but the challenge was very
few of those alerts were getting attention.
Or if they were getting attention, very few of them were converting to real
consults and addressing real patient need.
So first thing we saw was many more of the right patients getting flagged
and flagged earlier and at converting into
palliative care
consults and patients receiving follow-through care that's
appropriate. The second benefit we saw is dramatic reductions in
readmissions and 60-day readmissions in this patient
population. And then from an administrative perspective, reduction in
total cost of care.
So I spoke about, I'm right at 9:30, I spoke about a case
study in sepsis, I spoke about a case study in palliative
care. But the thing that to me is so exciting is that this
opportunity is not just limited to these two use cases, but are
possible in so many different clinical condition areas.
Below, what I'm showing you that this work was done
not just through the researchers and students and collaborators in my
lab and the team at Bayesian, but also now in many of
these areas, we are partnered with a variety of systems, include Cleveland
Clinic, Memorial Care, Mayo Clinic, Theta Care, MedStar, University of Rochester,
Innova, and what you'll see is a very diverse set of systems.
Systems with a large community system, systems that are premier academic
medical centers, systems that are regional
community hospitals, which means we're not just thinking of AI
as the kind of thing that is implemented for the wealthiest
hospitals or the most pristine hospitals, but we really want to bring it in a
way that we can bring this value to very diverse
populations and very diverse
settings. And if anyone is interested in learning more
or talking to me more about it or collaborating, here's my email address if
you'd like me to send an email. And I'll be around between
the opening of G and H outside if you'd
like to talk more for the next couple of hours. Thank you so much.
That was very impressive, I think, and we've seen how these technologies can not
just be developed, but also actually brought to clinical practice.
And now it's my great pleasure to introduce the final speaker of this
session, Dr. Faisal Mahmood from Harvard.
He's very well-known. He's maybe the godfather of
pathology foundation models. His team has published
several of the leading pathology foundation models that are being used by
teams worldwide, have been used in thousands of publications,
and now I'm very excited that he, I think, is also
going to present some new foundation models from his team that are not
just for pathology, but go beyond it and actually are
foundation models of everything.
So I would like to introduce Faisal here.
Please join me here on the stage, Faisal. Yep.
Thank you so much for the introduction and for inviting me to speak today.
So today I'll be talking about some of the work that my group has done in
developing foundation models for oncology.
We'll talk about some of the pathology foundation models that we have developed,
and also some of the new work that is coming out of our group.
Here are my disclosures.
So my group predominantly works on computational pathology, so we analyze images
that look something like this. So these are very large images
that come from digitized glass slides.
Pathology is often regarded as the last modality in cancer research to be
digitized, and that's because the standard of care still remains looking at a glass
slide under a microscope. And the goal of our team is really to go
from these images to everything in the red box here, from early diagnosis,
prognosis, looking at prediction of response to treatment, and so forth.
But we also integrate other kinds of data types to answer some of these
questions. So this is how we started to approach this problem of trying
to represent data
in a more meaningful way so we can do all of these different computational
tasks downstream.
So I always like to talk a little bit about the history of the field, and in
particular about Judith Prevette, because she was a forgotten hero
of this area.
She did some very interesting early work in the 1960s and '70s
in trying to analyze these microscopy images.
And what a lot of people don't know is that her work became the
basis of the very first FDA-approved
medical device that used some form of machine learning in the late
'80s and early '90s, and that was what's today is known as a
Genius Hologic device and is used for
Pap smear analysis and other kinds of cytology-based analysis.
But at the time, these images were very large, so they were
being patched and stored into magnetic tape and using simple line
profiles. So it's very interesting to see how her work has
had an influence on everything that is being done in computational
pathology today.
These images are very large, so in more recent times we've used all kinds of weakly
supervised methods. So these methods use whole slide images and
labels that reside in pathology reports or electronic medical records
to train these models. Two of the most common approaches for these
include the utility of graph convolutional neural networks or
multiple instance learning. So in
2019,
this real seminal article was published from the Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer
Center, where they showed that you needed about 10,000 or so whole slide images to
train a model that would get you to useful clinical
performance.
And when we started working in the area, we wanted to see if there's a
data-efficient way for us to do this.
And that's what led to a number of studies, but we came up with methods and
tools that we used to train machine learning models using
whole slide images and labels
that did not need pixel-level annotations.
And
we were able to do this in a data-efficient manner, which means we could apply it
to much more interesting problems.
We also made these tools publicly available, so there's an entire community of
people that have used these tools over the past six or seven years.
We applied this to cancer of unknown primary in 2021, trying to see if
we can predict origins for metastatic and unknown primary tumors
using a histology image alone. We looked at endomyocardial
biopsy assessment and also trying to integrate histology and molecular
data to see if we'll be able to build better
prognostic models.
But for all of these tools, we used multiple instance learning-based
framework, which uses whole slide image, which is patched into smaller
patches. We extract meaningful representations from these patches and
then learn on top of those representations.
Our earlier studies, the studies I just showed, used representations
that were just based on a ResNet that's trained on real-world images.
But they still performed reasonably, but over time, we realized that the feature
extraction component here is very important, and how we represent
these data is key to
improving these predictive models.
So we started experimenting with self-supervised learning early on, and then in
2024, we published these two foundation models.
And these foundation models focus on extracting meaningful representations from
pathology images,
but also trying to contrast with text to improve image
representations. This is just in line with what has happened in the machine
learning community, where they've tried to contrast images with text
representation to improve image representation.
So these models were made publicly available and have been downloaded over four
million times and have been used at this point in over 2,000 different studies.
So this really accelerated the utility of these models show that how
important self-supervision is and how important representing data into meaningful
representations can be. So these studies were focusing on
representing... regions of pathology slides, but we also wanted to
scale this to the entire slide. So last year we published Titan,
which is a foundation model that focuses on representing the entirety of a whole
slide image into a singular vector or representation.
And this used a number of different bells and whistles, including iBOT-based
training and using what's commonly used for
training large language models, where we train short and test long,
and train on a limited region of the slide and testing on a large region of
the slide. But we also used additional layers of
training, which includes using text, both from the
report and a generative model that had been developed in our group.
And we tried to show that we can improve slide level representations in
contrast with some of the other foundation models that were out there.
Also, we assessed what the scaling laws looked like.
And as our models are getting better, our benchmarks are also getting more
complex and difficult because all of the problems that we were trying to target
back in 2024,
these models already perform almost perfectly on those
tasks.
So we tried to represent the whole slide,
and we made these models publicly available as well.
But text is a very subjective modality, so we also
wanted to explore that can we contrast
with additional modalities such that it will improve image representation?
And there's a lot of more objective information about these
cases that we have available to us.
So we started contrasting with molecular information.
We started by looking at IHCs, contrasting with IHCs to see if the
representation would improve, and then doing the same
with molecular data or transcriptomics in a really toy-based setting.
So this is just by using the TCGA. And we showed that you could really improve
few-shot performance
quite a lot. That means using very, very few labels or very, very few
samples for training
these models,
and still converging to a clinically useful result.
So this was early indication that this is an approach that we should scale, and
that's where we started to develop Threads, which is a model that uses
all of the molecular data that was available to us at MGB as well as at
Dana-Farber, where we tried to contrast between H&E
images and corresponding molecular
data. To improve representation, we showed that you could focus on or
target more difficult problems like treatment response prediction
directly from the histology slide.
So this is a study that will come out in the coming months, and we do have plans to
make this model publicly available as well.
We also try to expand this to spatial proteomic
data. So this is a model for spatial proteomics that we developed
in the group using large amounts of data and self-supervision.
The goal is the same. Can we represent proteomic data into meaningful
representations that can then be used for a host of different downstream tasks?
This includes tissue phenotyping, looking at artifact classification and so forth,
but also using it as a search engine to retrieve
similar regions within spatial proteomic data, as well as for spatial
biomarker discovery. So we have an earlier version of this model that was already
made available, and if people would like to get access to the newer
version of the model, there's a QR code that you can use
to sign up for the new version that will
be coming out. And my colleague, Shizun,
will be giving a talk about this, and we also have a poster on this
foundation model, and hopefully the study will also come out later this year.
But as we have continued to develop these models, we started
by looking at regions within a pathology slide, which we tried to
contrast with other modalities to improve image representation.
We scaled it to the entirety of the slide, and then we can represent the
whole slide. But something that we've been trying to do
for the past three years or so is trying to represent the entire
patient. So now it's commonly referred to as virtual patient representation,
but at the time, we just called it representing the entire patient's
record.
The goal was that can we use everything digital that we
have about the patient and represent the patient into a singular
vector that can then be used for a lot of different downstream
applications? And these applications can be
predictive. They can be related to diagnosis, prognosis, treatment response
prediction, next event prediction, hospital operations.
But just having something that represents the patient
into a meaningful representation would be incredibly valuable.
And we wanted this to be dynamic and continuously updating because we have a lot of
information about the patient
at any given point in time, but that information also continues
to evolve as we get more and more data into
the system. So we used all of the data that was available to us at
Mass General Brigham. This includes about 12 hospitals,
and this is data from about 7.2 million patients that were used to
develop this model, and it has about 18 different modalities.
And the goal is that as more and more data will become available about the patient,
we will represent it into a singular vector or singular representation for that
patient. So the representation would evolve
over time, and we'll also have a patient trajectory as to how the
patient and its representation evolves.
So once we have this representation, we can look at risks, predictions,
similarity searching, statistical analysis, other kinds of treatment response
predictions. So the single vector would be incredibly useful for us, right?
So these are all downstream tasks or applications that we can potentially
look at. But once we have these representations,
we can look at how the different concepts in
medicine cluster together. This is a very nice plot
where we have an entire atlas of medicine being learned on
its own from these
representations. And you can look at the fact that
particularontologies
that we know from literature all clustered
together, even though they were not given to the model
during training. The model is unaware of all the literature
that we have about these different ontologies, and yet it
manages to cluster these ontologies all together.
And then you can also go in and study different relationships that
exist across modalities.
These are all ways to see how rich these representations are and
how meaningful representations does the model
learn?
We can also look at individual embeddings.
So in this case, each dot represents the
embedding of the entire patient, or everything that we know about the patient,
including structured and unstructured data, and it's colored by
age.
And then once you have these embeddings and these
representations, you're also able to look for similar
patients. So in an entire record, in a large record, are you able
to find similar patients? Because similarity search or patient
matching is a problem that can solve a lot of issues that we
have, both in oncology and in medicine in general.
This includes looking at patients who might respond to a clinical trial, looking at
rare disease diagnosis, and so forth.
So here we have examples for how well the model
does in finding similar patients, and here's some examples for oncology, and we
have a baseline that's for the last progress note.
So just embedding the last progress note versus embedding the entire
patient's record.
We can do similarity search based on text.
So we can use text to find
if there's a similar patient in the entire record, or we can
also use other modalities. Because it's a multimodal model, you can start with an
image or text or any other modality to see whether you'll be able to
find any similar patients. And
there's also a score for how similar the corresponding patient
might be. So obviously, this model is very new, and we're still
exploring what the capabilities of the model are, but image search is definitely,
or patient search is definitely one of those applications that we are very
interested in and we continue to devote a lot of effort towards.
We can also look at preclinical evidence.
So I think one of the
basic promises of machine learning and medicine is early diagnosis.
And we've seen
a host of different studies over the past five years showing that you can use all
these different auxiliary modalities to predict disease risk.
For example, looking at retinal images, you can predict cardiovascular and cancer
risk and so forth.
And so in this case, what we have is that we have 18 different
modalities all merged into a singular vector or a representation for the patient,
and then we use that representation in a more supervised problem downstream to try
to see if we were able to predict those diseases early on.
And for many of these
diseases, we do see that we can predict them earlier.
We can also look at disease progression,
and trying to see what the progression of the disease would be.
The baseline here is just an age, sex baseline, so a very simplistic
baseline. But we show that using this representation that includes
both
structured and unstructured data, you can improve both
early diagnosis of disease as well as disease progression.
And then you can also look at treatment outcome predictions, because I think this
is important. We want to know which drugs the patient would
respond to.
And you could do that in a retrieval setting where you're finding similar cases,
but here it's being posed as a supervised problem.
And then you can also, because you have representations of patients, you can
also look at clinical operation management as a
whole as well. And then here are just some results
for cancer survival and
progression, and also some baselines for what happens when you use
structured and unstructured data,
as well as some very fundamental age, sex baselines as well.
You can also stratify patients into distinct risk groups.
This is just by using the representation itself, and
we also studied that these stratifications are
also well calibrated.
So once we have these representations and we've used them in some kind of
supervised downstream tasks, then we can also go back and
assess
the interpretability of these
supervised models as well as those representations.
But we want to see that what the model uses in making some of these
predictions and how the risk of the patient evolves over time, and this is an
example here that we can study how the risk of the patient is evolving over
time and what is responsible for that risk evolution.
So you can study this at the level of the patient, but you can also study this at
the level of the large cohorts, so that can lead to
discovery
of additional information, additional knowledge.
This is something that we are still exploring and will take more time for us to see
whether it has any discovery potential.
So this is just a flavor of
what's coming. This is a very early stage study,
and we've been working in this direction for a while, but we will continue to work
to validate this model and see what
the capabilities of the models are.
So you can download a preprint
using this QR code, and the preprint would also be available on arXiv
in the coming
days. So I'll stop here in the interest of time, and I'd like to thank
all the PhD students and postdocs who have contributed to this work over the
years, as well as all the funding that we've
received to make this work possible. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much. It's truly an AI revolution in cancer
research. Thank you very much for joining today's plenary session.
Please come back next year. There's much more to come, and I wish you a
nice conference. Thank you.